the Joe Rogan experience because they're
on the other team yeah dude that shit's
that's terrifying
that shit's really sad but it never used
to be the left that's what's the
scariest thing to me the left was never
like advocating violence they were the
exact opposite during the Vietnam War
they were the hippies they're the people
that wanted to bring the troops home
they're the people that didn't want war
they didn't want violence they didn't
want hate they denounced hate now
they're like they're like talking about
violence being the answer Isis certain
certain political movements I said bunch
of Nazi I saw a term on reddit that I
liked a lot called liberal Baptist have
you heard of this no so basically the
idea is like you know like in
fundamentalism of any sort really like
the idea is when you're saying that
you're religious it's you you're not
really interested in another person's
soul or saving another person what
you're interested in doing is creating
an ethical hierarchy that you can
dominate by being at the top of the
ethical hierarchy right so what you're
running into with this [ __ ] that you're
talking about is people if you don't
really seem so concerned with how
society is supposed to be as much as
using their refined system that they've
come up with which there is like they
call being woke or you know what I mean
it's like this is sort of crazy it's
hard to even keep up with it right but
they use it to try to dominate the
people around them by making you scared
to speak your mind because the ideas
it's like you know one of the eye I want
to mic the guests of my podcast that I
get [ __ ] yelled at more than anybody
else for having on Jordan Peterson that
really pissed a lot of people after I
had him on my podcast why because they
feel they misunderstand him and they
think that Jordan Peterson hates
transgendered people I think or they
thing that Yi's a I think that he's they
think that he's like all right
they think that he's like some kind of
outright spokesman and the truth of the
matter is I don't I don't fully know all
of jort the spectrum of Jordan
Peterson's views on
because it would take me a very long
time to do that I know he's [ __ ]
smart I know it was really cool for him
to come on my podcast and I know we had
a really great conversation they didn't
really talk about that stuff right but
it didn't fit the narrative that they
want the the narrative that they want is
that he's a hateful person and that he
hates transgender people right and that
he's a bigot and he's just right-wing
all right poster boy but it's not real
the problem is people aren't willing to
adjust that once they stand on that
stance once they have that position that
this is I'm left-wing this guy's
right-wing he's a pig he's ruining
things like that's they just make up
their mind but get it can we throw it
let me add one thing to this okay
imagine this imagine Jordan Peterson and
I don't honestly I don't know but just
imagine there is a piece of him that
doesn't for whatever reason like I don't
know I'm again I'm not saying this isn't
I have no I'm not implying it either I'm
just saying imagine [ __ ] Jordan
Peterson I don't know I'm trying to
think of some offensive thing that he
just imagined he had some piece of him
right it was definitely politically not
correct right okay that doesn't mean
that all the other [ __ ] he's saying is
invalidated by some piece of him because
people are made up of lots of different
pieces well that's basically in a way
I'm not categorizing Jordan Peterson the
way you categorize Descartes but that's
what he was saying right that with great
people they also have what was the word
he used not great sin but great who was
the word he used to remember the word
the expression he got [ __ ] they've got
[ __ ] got [ __ ] yeah
great flaws and this is different vices
this would be said this is to me where
the big [ __ ] problem is is that
people have lost the ability to be
nuanced and people have and that to me
is where things are really [ __ ] up
right now which is like you were
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
yes and I'm not saying like oh let's
give a platform to people who have like
hate speech yeah but I vote to the idea
that we have gotten to the point now
we're just like free balling and
throwing around ideas just like we've
done all over the place here I guarantee
you when I look at Twitter there
going to be at least like five people
being like you [ __ ] cut piece of [ __ ]
only because like I'm throwing around
ideas because my hope is through that
process I'm gonna get closer to the
truth and I'm gonna be able to look at
myself like what you said about the [ __ ]
the Koch boy you know what I mean
I liked it because you're right and I
like what you did even though his
comedic is funny you're right dude why
am i giving that guy a hard [ __ ]
times he gonna do he can't not be born a
coke son right he's like he can't change
his birth yes who he is
meanwhile what's he doing is he taking
over countries in Africa no he's making
cute shirts and he's banging a hot woman
yeah so that's so that but I like I like
that having these kinds of interactions
with friends because it helps me adjust
even though I don't have any real
animosity for the coke brother from that
kind of thing I can look at my own
[ __ ] pattern and be like whoa [ __ ]
yeah that's like a that's something to
think about because I like I could be
more compassionate there yeah so my
point is what what what ends up
happening and what leads to someone who
started off being you know who's a who
considers themselves part of a group
that was that's trying to stop war that
spawned the hippy movement and now
they're like thankful that a train
accident happened that is a result of
gradually shutting down their ability to
understand that a human is much more
than just one [ __ ] thing Jeff
Sessions is not just an anti marijuana
person Jeff Sessions is probably an elf
in a sweet outfit that and a person
who's got a lot of love in him it has
done a lot of good things for a lot of
people but also he's got the worst
[ __ ] concept of what marijuana is and
that sucks but that doesn't invalidate
any of the love he's expressed
throughout his life and this is
unbearable for some people to deal with
because we want a Darth Vader well it's
because we are inclined to gravitate
towards tribalism it is a part of being
human being it's always going to be a
part it's the same reason why those
egyptologist we're rejecting these ideas
from John Anthony West and Robert Schoch
because they weren't a part of the tribe
yes these new people coming in with some
[ __ ] that they didn't figure out on
their own there's a thing that people do
on whether it's male versus female you
see
a lot of this one comes to this me to
stuff one of the weirdest things that
happens is that you start getting this
divide where the men are mad at the
women and the women of the matter that
men even people that are non offenders
and non victims yeah well they sure up
on teams yeah yes it's good that people
being exposed for doing bad things to
people but it's also very dangerous for
us to just men and women be on opposite
teams were humans right we're supposed
to be nice to each other it's goes back
to what we were talking about earlier we
we don't say that enough I really don't
think we say that enough I really think
we need to it needs it should be
reinforced and it sounds like oh it's a
[ __ ] great thing that's your advice
bro be nice to each other
yeah yes it is my advice it's not my
only advice right I think you should
also get your [ __ ] together I think you
should have some [ __ ] discipline yeah
I think you should eat right I think
she'd do a lot of things you should read
books I think you should pay attention I
think you try to educate yourself I
think you should try to be aware about
objectivity and tribalism more aware of
the influence but I also think it would
be really nice if we all just agreed to
be nicer to each other
[Applause]